after every harvest Thailand's rice
farmers burn off the remaining rice
straw and stubble to clear their land
the acrid smoke carries far and wide on
the wind in the northern province of
lampung the harvest is underway since
early in the morning
women have been out in the fields
cutting the sheaves with vesicles
finally it's time for a lunch break
we've been doing this work for
generations it's not a big deal we women
are strong there's a lot of straw left
on the field typically a kilogram per
kilogram of rice if it's left to rot
it'll release methane a potent
greenhouse gas but burning the straw
emits co2 and creates fine particulate
matter that's harmful to people and the
environment
yakov on come one wants to change things
after completing her studies in Bangkok
she decided to return to her home
village and develop an alternative
farmer Oscar patience is very hard
working when I see they grow rice until
is grow like this it takes a long time
and after I saw each burn is very sad
when I come to my hometown I don't share
their life they still claw rice much I
find solutions for them instead of
burning for the entrepreneur rice straw
is not waste to be disposed of but a
valuable resource she pays the farmers
the equivalent of 3 cents a kilo
the golden stalks are brought by the
truckload to her nearby Factory
here the straw is chopped up because the
air is full of fine straw particles
everyone has to wear a face mask
then the small pieces of straw are mixed
with hot water no chemicals are added
but the mixture has to boil for four
hours
that produces a pulpy mass which is then
cleaned and dried on the factory floor
we meet up again with a farmers from the
rice field this is a very good thing it
used to be that we had no work after the
rice harvest but with this factory job I
can improve my income the pulp is used
to make biodegradable paper and
packaging but machines to process the
pulp are expensive so the entrepreneur
exports the raw material to India we
have the India customer because in India
there are there are a lot of our modding
and tableware manufacturers and the
lives of the raw material and they
contact us and they are very interesting
in our product because it is a
biodegradable product the special
feature of the tableware is a thin
coating of rice starch which helps the
product resist grease heat and liquids
in a two-hour test with a papaya salad
the dish stayed leak-proof
the next day we pay a visit to the city
of Chiang Mai the economic and cultural
heart of northern Thailand
yah-hoo one can one stops by a Buddhist
temple but her actual destination lies
on the outskirts of the city the Science
and Technology Park of Chiang Mai
University the auditorium at the center
of the campus is known appropriately
enough as the rice grain
here scientists support Thai startups
with their expertise the other one comma
one would like to manufacture takeaway
food packaging made of rice straw in her
own factory she hopes that will become
financially feasible by 2020 she's
especially interested in the researchers
work on improving the rice starch film
so that it takes longer to dissolve
thus from Iraq for him you can't change
and by some chemical new chemical for
natural for that process like
I survived inside of beams the TV's
maybe four and finals but do people in
Chiangmai need tableware made of rice
straw as in most cities in Thailand life
here is largely outdoors the hundreds of
street vendors and food stands all use
disposable containers if you want to
start up your own production one vendor
says then pay attention to the sizes the
bowls shouldn't be too large or the
customers will think the portions are
too small and the price is important one
but but piece would be okay one part is
the equivalent of three cents there has
a lot of shop that concerns about the
environmental issue and it's also I see
lighter policy from the cup woman is
more stronger than the past they ban to
use foam and plastic they encouraged the
restaurant
our Archie used biodegradable packaging
back in her home village yahwah venkamma
wong is visiting her grandparents
yeah but ham ha ha my wire this is where
she started her business a few years ago
she carried out her first experiments
with rice straw pulp in her
grandmother's cooking pots at first her
grandparents were far from thrilled is
this why they had sent that grandchild
to study at great expense in the capital
but meanwhile they have ample reason to
be proud of her and as the saying goes
the rice farmers of lampung have learned
how to turn straw into gold because
burning it would be a terrible waste
you